[Music]
I'm Darby Harper just watch me are you
sitting down for this I see dead people
I help them pass on to the next wrong
you'd think that'd be my life's biggest
burden but it is a distant second to
where I'm forced to spend my days
high school that's Capri Donahue head
cheerleader isn't cheer just for shallow
hot girls I'm so glad you asked and the
answer is that's offensive
Jeffrey knows I'm the one person she
can't get to like her Darby forgot you
went here
Capri give me my clothes why would I
take her clothes so planning on
attending a funeral she can be a little
sister sometimes extra psychotic
I'm reporting live
Frederick Douglass High School where
yesterday students witnessed the
shocking death of head cheerleader
Caffrey Donahue
wake up [ __ ] oh God damn it you can't
see me what are you doing here my sweet
17 is coming up in a month all I want is
this party help me then I'll move on in
what world do you think I can throw your
dream party in a world where I make you
popular enough to do it
who is that I want her but
any press is good press
[Music]
ing a dead person
he is a very traumatic experience you
look like you've just seen a ghost
no bullying
I think it's criminally good haunting
[Music]
thank you
[Music]